this massive ant colony maintains
cohesion through constant chemical
communication this signalling method
facilitates the collection of food
defense of the colony and very creepily
collection of their dead
however chemical signatures can be
minute this enables the zou Darian
spider to lurk and hunt amidst the ants
if the spider is recognized as a foreign
creature the ants will kill her they're
kind of xenophobia she spots a loner
that has stopped for a bit of grooming
and injects her paralytic venom she then
uses the corpse of her victim as
camouflage the ants sent masks her own
this the spider I gotta tell you is the
worst creature of the world using her
disguise and the scent of her prey to
mislead the other hats she makes her
escape once at a safe distance she sucks
the juices out of her victim and returns
to her deck and cements her place within
my nightmares
for years to come so to recap the zou
Darian spider finds an ant colony goes
inside finds a loner and kills it wears
its skin as camouflage and uses it sent
to help mask its escape it is a serial
killer I mean there's no other way to
say it we probably have an FBI profile
on this thing it is Menace it needs to
be stopped
and and I don't know who's brave enough
to do it it's certainly not me
[Music]
you